ربما تكون المدافع قد صمتت هنا ،
لكن المعركة من أجل هذه الزاوية من سوريا
لم تنته بعد ، هناك هدوء مخادع ،
لكن كل خطوة قد تكون قاتلة
قبل أيام قليلة ، قُتل جندي تركي في
انفجار يفعل بالضبط ما يفعله هؤلاء
الجنود نحن  انضموا إلى الجيش التركي
في مهمتهم لإزالة الألغام من
بلدة طالب ييد ، لذلك تم تطهير هذه المنطقة
من قبل من قبل القوات التركية ،
لكن ما يكتشفونه هو
أن هناك خلايا لا تزال نشطة في
هذه المنطقة ، ما يفعلونه هو أنهم ما زالوا
يأتون  عادوا وقاموا بزرع المتفجرات وهذا
هو سبب عمليات التطهير المستمرة التي تجريها
،
ويبدو الآن أن القوات هنا قد عثرت على
جهاز كانوا على وشك تفجيره ، قام
الفريق بعزل الموقع قبل
تفجير القنبلة بأمان أخبرنا الجنود
أنهم وجدوا عشرة  مئات الأجهزة التي
تُترك كل يوم وراءنا ، يقولون إن عدوًا
مصممًا على تدمير وعد تركيا
بمنطقة آمنة ،
ندخل المدينة بعد ساعات فقط من
انفجار سيارة مفخخة في السوق هناك
لم تقع إصابات هذه المرة لكن الناس
ما زالوا في الحقيقة من هجوم مروع
بالقنابل قبل ثلاثة أيام فقط
يخبرنا الناس هنا أنهم
يعرفون هؤلاء الضحايا أنهم كانوا
الصيادلة المحليين صاحب المتجر
وأطفاله امرأة كانت تتسوق
مع أطفالها  الناس
هنا يخافون من أن هذا قد
يكون مجرد بداية لهذه الأنواع من
الهجمات الألمانية تركيا ، وربما أعني رثاء
لكن أي نوع من أمريكا وهذا
هو الهدف من هذه التفجيرات أقول تركيا
تدعم القوات السورية
l'histoire جالا بيل مكابي الموزع
مسلم هم  على النحو الواجب فيما يتعلق بما عيني
إيكشيل لها توفار آسف مالكولم
إلكتريك وحيث كاترينا التي عذبت المونتي
كارما مصل ميسولا هوندا نجمة مافيا ميسولا هوندا
هي المافيا كوسيلة لريموند
مثل هذا البالغ من العمر 20 عامًا الآن في الحجز
مما يجعل أقل من مائة دولار
شهريًا تم إغراؤه ليس  بالسياسة ولكن
عن طريق المال السهل لزرع القنابل نيابة
عن SDS يخبرنا أنه لا يمكننا التحقق
من مزاعمه وتقول قوات سوريا الديمقراطية إنها
إنكار لا أساس له أن لديهم أي
علاقة بأي تفجيرات لم يدعي أحد
وقوع أي من هذه الهجمات على مدار السنوات التسع
الماضية من الحرب ، وقد شهدت هذه المدينة الحدودية الصغيرة
كل شيء يتبدل عدة
مرات
الآن حان دور الديوك الرومية لمحاولة تحقيق
الاستقرار هنا في الأيام الأولى
ولن يكون الأمر
سهلاً بالنسبة للمدنيين الذين
يضطرون مرة أخرى إلى التقاط أجزاء من
حياتهم المحطمة جيمانا كراتشي تيليبودس سي إن إن
سوريا